The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I just came across a
couple of interesting quotes
about cybernetics.
What did cybernetics have
to do with any of this?
Well, an awful lot.
Here's a quote from
Jerry Wiesner.
"We were all fired up by Norbert
Wiener's cybernetics.
We have explored the far-ranging
implications of
the complex concepts
of information and
communication theory.
It ranged from man-made
communications to computing
systems to the sciences of
man, inquiries into the
structure and development of
the nervous system, the
phenomena of inner life and
behavior in relation to other
men."
So you get the sense of, like,
the whole interdisciplinary
thing, which is a big
topic, of course,
on our campus today.
RLE was one of the major kind
of early points in that.
"Neurophysiologists and other
biologists, linguistics,
economists, social scientists,
and psychologists recognized
almost intuitively the
usefulness and relevance of
feedback information theory
to their fields.
For all of them, the concepts of
information theory, coding,
feedback, prediction, and
filtering provide new pathways
to explore pathways that seemed
to wind unendingly."
So this whole idea--
this is another one of these
places where you see the
relationship between the
institutional structures at
MIT, how the labs are organized,
what the overall
policy is that's coming from
the federal government to
support the work, and actually
the content of the work, what
sorts of things people are
studying, how they're thinking
about these problems, what
the innovations are.
And, I think-- and this is one
of the threads I want to
communicate to you today--
there's a real common thread in
a lot of what MIT does in
these realms, including SAGE
and Lincoln Labs and that
stuff, going back from probably
before the war around
computing and interaction and
all the different aspects of
communications.
The Department of Linguistics
itself is formed by research
from RLE in 1961.
There's actually a real
relationship between, for
those of you familiar--
anybody know what Chomsky
and linguistics is?
So Noam Chomsky, who is the sort
of founding father, in a
lot of ways, of modern
linguistics, created this idea
in the '50s called generative
grammar, which is the idea
that the structures
of language are
built into the brain.
They're not things that you
learn as a toddler or as baby.
And that's one of the special
things that makes human brains
different from all other
kinds of brains.
And that's called generative
grammar--
that the basic grammars
are some that is
inherently inside of you.
A very radical idea, at the
time, for a number of
different reasons, partly
because it was connected to
what's called the cognitive
revolution in psychology.
Up until that point, the kind
of leading paradigm, even in
Cambridge psychology, was
behaviorism led by B. F.
Skinner at Harvard.
The idea that, well, it's too
complicated to understand
what's going on inside either
our brains or anybody's, any
animals' brains.
We're just going to look at the
behaviors, the inputs and
the outputs, measure the
behaviors, and try to
understand that anything that's
going on inside only
matters if it's expressed in
a particular behavior.
Well, around this time period,
led by many people around
here, there's a thing called the
cognitive revolution, they
call it now, where people
rejected that view.
And they began looking inside
what thinking was all about,
very much driven by parallel
developments in
computing, in AI.
And in some sense, the whole
idea of psychology at MIT was
superseded by what?
Cognitive science.
Which now we have a Department
of Brain and Cognitive
Science, which was sort of--
do we have a psychology
department here?
No.
We used to, at one point,
but we don't anymore.
It was sort of folded in.
It's interesting.
It's a separate topic and way
to think about what those
differences are.
Partly, I'm dwelling on this
because tomorrow is the
symposium, the last of the 150th
Anniversary Symposia,
which is on Brains, Minds, and
Machines, and is a new
research initiative that's
trying to look at the problem
of intelligence by combining
AI, cognitive science,
neuroscience, and linguistics.
And these things are all not
that far apart, again, from
this early history, but they've
developed separately,
in some ways, for the last 50
years, and the idea is to tie
them together.
So if you're familiar with AI,
there's not been a lot of
neuroscience in AI.
But now there's an attempt to
bring a lot of that together.
It's going to be a really
interesting, exciting thing.
I have to introduce the
symposium tomorrow night, and
I'm working on my comments.
And, usually, when I introduce
these symposia, I talk about
what happened at MIT before
the people in
the room were there.
And then, when they got up and
they talk about their own
experiences, then they cover
the last 50 or 60 years.
There's not much that happened
at MIT in linguistics or in
psychology or in anything
cognitive before Marvin Minsky
and Noam Chomsky and a
few of these other
sort of critical people.
Interestingly, the
whole efforts--
these things also manifested
themselves in biology.
How do you think, in the 1950s,
biology took up some of
this influence from cognitive
science or, particularly, from
communications theory?
What's the word that people
use to describe DNA?
A code.
The whole idea of DNA as a code
and biology as a kind of
informational science emerges
right at this time, not only
at MIT, a lot of other places,
but very much taken up there.
Last year we read an article
about that, but we compressed
the syllabus a little bit.
OK.
The political context
during those years--
after the war, again, the
Radiation Lab dies down.
The country is really
demobilizing.
Troops are coming back
from the war.
Everybody's going away from the
military back to civilian
life, until 1949, 1952.
Critical events happen then.
Anybody want to guess?
Russians explode an H-bomb in
1949, much, much sooner than
anybody expected, and the Korean
War starts in 1950.
And that's really the beginning
of the Cold War.
So you really have this--
it's not correct to think about
the Cold War as just the
continuation of World War II.
There is this sort of brief--
but it is a kind of 5-year
period where everything's
shrinking before the Cold War
really gets going.
And then you begin, during the
'50s, you really have the
civilian sense of being under
threat by nuclear warfare.
It was before my time, but
perhaps your parents or even
your grandparents
will remember.
In the 1950s, if you were in an
elementary school in this
country, you were trained how to
respond to a nuclear attack
when you were in school.
And you'll hear the phrase "duck
and cover," which so
many people were
trained to do.
Hide under your desk, pretty
much, which I'll leave it as
an exercise to the reader to
what that'll do for you when
there's a nuclear
weapon coming.
And so during this period, in
some sense, it's the golden
age of science policy.
People often talk about that.
And we'll come back to this
after Sputnik, where
scientists are involved in
high-level decision making in
a way they've never really
been since then.
In the world of computers, all
the way up through 1960,
three-quarters of the world of
computing was simply run and
funded by the government.
So there was hardly any
computation to speak of.
And the quarter that was not
there was mostly in the
business world of punch cards
and IBM punch card machines.
And a lot of that work was done
in high-end computational
at Los Alamos, fluid dynamic
simulations and things for
nuclear weapons.
So during the Cold War, you have
all kinds of new kinds of
institutions emerging, in
addition to new technologies.
Outside of MIT, you have
the Rand Corporation.
Anybody hear of the Rand
Corporation before?
It's still around.
You still hear them issuing
reports and things.
I have colleagues
who work there.
Founded in 1946 by the Air
Force, and that's the place
that pretty much invented
the term "think tank."
So you have these kind
of not governmental--
Rand is not part of
the government--
but it's a not-for-profit
corporation where they do a
lot of large-scale strategy,
operations
research, nuclear strategy.
I mentioned already the Office
of Naval Research, which sort
of carries on the OSRD tradition
for the 10 years
after the Second World War.
And they came up in the reading
because they funded
the early part of Whirlwind and
lots of different types of
new theories, from engineering
science--
you hear that phrase coming up
a lot at MIT in that period--
systems engineering, systems
dynamics, systems analysis,
operations research.
I mentioned cybernetics,
control theory, general
systems theory.
And all this stuff is sort
of buzzing around.
And before I show you this
film about Whirlwind--
well, let me show you the
film about Whirlwind.
OK.
And so then, the other one
I called up is the--
you'll remember from
the reading
that they build Whirlwind.
It starts out as this sort of
flight simulator thing.
Rather quickly, Jay Forrester
has these huge ambitions for
it and starts into
this just large
machine computation project.
And then they switch their Navy
funding into Air Force
funding, and they look at this
problem of air defense.
Starting in the early '50s,
there's a physicist at MIT
named George Valley.
And they start looking at this
whole business about how do we
defend the continent, which is
an interesting question.
Remember, we talked last time,
or the time before, about
anti-aircraft control.
SAGE is really the exact same
thing, just the updated '50s
version of it, right?
How do you shoot down
airplanes that
are attacking you?
And air defense is a typical
problem that civilian
scientists like, and that
government, especially elected
officials, like because it
plays well politically.
It seems to be, morally, a
little bit more comfortable
than offensive weapons.
Of course, you can shoot someone
down if they're are
about to drop bombs on you.
The military, also, generally
dislikes it because the people
who run the world regarding
aircraft in the military--
even at this point, they
were the Air Force--
the Air Force doesn't like to
think a lot about shooting
down airplanes.
It's not one of their favorite
hobby topics.
And they generally aren't
big on defense.
They want to go out and kill
the enemy and offense.
So you constantly see this
question of air defense rising
up in scientific circles.
It's still true today, actually,
with things like
missile defense.
And they put this system
together called SAGE--
and, again, you read
about it--
sort of continental air defense
system, I think,
partly comes from the way that
engineering really dominated
here, above the other
sciences.
And in many of these other
schools were--
where the engineering is
sort of separated off
as a separate school--
but the really high-prestige
work was going to the
mathematicians.
I also think that, actually,
a lot of the history of
computing was written later
by mathematicians.
And so they kind of remade it
the way they wanted it to.
You can see--
actually, even Norbert Wiener
does that, John Von Neumann.
John Von Neumann plays a role
in the ENIAC project very,
very late and does some very
important fundamental,
theoretical work, but
it's basically
an engineering project.
Whereas here, partly because
of the military connection,
partly because of the Rad Lab,
there's always this focus on
the human relationship and the
real-time interaction, and
partly because they're enabled
to do these big projects and
kind of build these big,
experimental systems, rather
than having one single.
There's a great quote.
It's from later on, where a
university administrator is
told that they just, the
University, just bought a
giant computer for millions of
dollars, and now they need to
form a department of
computer science.
And the administrator says,
that's ridiculous.
We just bought a giant air
conditioning unit for millions
of dollars.
Nobody's telling me I need to
make a department of air
conditioning science.
And so the struggles of sort
of-- is the computer just a
big, glorified calculator,
or is it something
fundamentally new--
are all happening during
this period, too.
Anybody know when the
Computer Science
Department here is founded?
Everything I'm showing
you here is from the
'50s, 1950 to 1956.
When does MIT create the
CS part of EECS?
1968.
Takes a long time to actually
recognize that there's a new
science there.
As I said, this is
really IBM PR.
So they were showing this to
maybe generals and other
people who would be their
military customers or just
generally the public.
It's not very technical.
It's, like, got the kids on the
playground, like defending
your people sort of thing.
But you see throughout this
the computers are there as
these control centers.
And this is real-time
interactive computer graphics,
which is going on nowhere else
in the world at the time.
And the idea of a computer,
not as this kind of
calculator/switcher, but
as this interactive--
not just interactive
but also very much
networked kind of computer.
Some of the things you saw that
were really done for the
first time with SAGE and
Whirlwind, real time, they
mention graphic displays.
Modems were invented
for this system.
You don't even use
modems anymore.
Does anybody have a modem that
they use these days?
I haven't used one in, probably,
close to 10 years at
this point, but used
to use them a lot.
Real-time memory allocation,
all kinds of stuff that you
use in the software
engineering world.
And SAGE was really the first
big software project, too.
It really taught the American
industry how to organize these
big software projects.
And there were many others
that were built that were
similar to it.
And as the film kind of
makes clear, it's
oriented towards civilians.
It's built to make civilians
feel comfortable.
It's not built because the
military wants to go out and
get the Soviet Union.
That's what they do
for a living.
And it's built to make people
feel comfortable.
And was pretty much obsolete
by the time it was
operational, so it had,
essentially, no military
impact despite all the money
that was spent on it.
But it had some technological
input.
Nobody's really ever was able
to know if it would have
worked if we were actually
attacked.
But there was a brief period
where air attack by Soviet
bombers over the North Pole was
a great fear of people.
What ended that fear or
made it irrelevant?
AUDIENCE: ICBMs.
PROFESSOR: ICBMs.
Where this system wouldn't
work against ICBMs.
But you still see that fear.
And all the debates about
missile defense
in the last 20 years--
Patriot missile during the Gulf
War and all that stuff--
is just an extension of
this kind of fear.
So this is sort of
what's going on
around here in the '50s.
I have a couple more videos,
let me see which ones.
And a lot of people really
actually did question, is this
really the kind of MIT that
we want to be living in--
big military projects, lots of
money flowing in, lots of
focus on building
large systems--
as opposed to research projects
or kind of individual
scientists doing things?
And that's where-- and I want to
say a little bit before we
move on, and Roz Williams
mentioned this.
I don't think we've assigned
it this year for reading.
Was a bunch of people at MIT
got together in 1949.
It was called the Committee on
the Educational Survey, but it
became known as the
Lewis Report.
And, again, Roz Williams
mentions it.
The Lewis--
who it was named after was her
grandfather, Doc Louis of
chemical engineering.
Other people on the committee
were Stratton, who I
mentioned, Elting Morison, who
was a historian who actually
founded the department that I
head now, Viki Weisskopf, who
was a famous Manhattan
Project-era physicist.
Jerry Wiesner we've
talked about.
Gordon Brown we talked about.
John Burchard, who was the first
Dean of Humanities and
Social Sciences, and Harold
Hazen, who was the Dean of
Engineering at the time that
we talked about before.
And there were these problems
that were on peoples' mind at
the beginning of the Cold War.
I'll read you a couple of quotes
from it, which are
pretty interesting.
"We continue to claim that our
primary mission is to teach,
but other activities
have assumed an
unprecedented role at MIT.
Service to the community and to
the national government has
always been recognized as a
primary obligation, but now
the dollar volume of government
contracts,
government-sponsored research,
amounts to far more than the
academic budget.
Postwar government funds have
been used to maintain a very
large technical staff without
the privilege of tenure.
And the major part of the
Institute's personnel is now
dependent on the
continuation of
short-term financial support.
Government money has made
available to us magnificent
facilities that have become
a permanent part of the
Institute and that involve
continued responsibility for
their maintenance."
So there was this problem
of just big size.
Like how do you maintain it?
Once the Institute grew that
big, people had to-- it's like
a big animal in a cage that you
need to shovel money into
all the time.
Whereas before, the Institute
was primarily focused on
undergraduate education, and
it was really a kind of
technical institute college
kind of environment.
It became much more focused
on research.
And these sponsored projects,
particularly military
sponsored, were bigger
and bigger.
They asked, "Is all this work
genuinely creative?
Can it, indeed, be justified
on the ground that it
strengthens our educational
program?
Have our staff members not
on occasion been lured by
prestige that accompanies an
enlargement of activities
without considering the loss
in their professional
competence that the undertaking
of added
administrative burdens
may entail?
So these were all real questions
that come up for the
next 60 years, in
a way, about--
are the faculty members now
big managers managing big
research projects more than real
thinkers sitting down and
actually thinking
things through?
"Is there not a danger that the
interests and energy of
our faculty are being diverted
from education to
income-producing work?
And secondly, many large
projects emphasize design and
construction problems--
like Whirlwind, SAGE--
engineering development or
applications of science rather
than fundamental scientific
inquiry.
We must be careful lest the
great preponderance of
activities of this type divert
interest from the more
fundamental aspects of
scientific research.
And the third concern is the
preponderance of military
projects in the sponsored
programs.
Two difficulties--
first, national security
requires some of
it be done in secret.
And second, it would be
unfortunate for MIT to become
regarded as an institution
that is dependent on the
development of war weapons as
it is for an industrial
organization to be
[? required ?]
in a similar light.
We suggest that future planning
should look forward
to the possibility of increased
emphasis on
activities more directly
related to the public
welfare."
This is a very interesting
moment where major people at
MIT get together and they say,
is this really the world that
we want to live in?
What's happening to MIT?
Is this really a good idea?
And again, that's 1949, right--
really, the year
before the Cold War
really hits.
And a lot of people feel those
concerns were sort of buried
throughout the '50s, in a way,
as the Institute became more
and more dependent
on these things.
A couple other things to mention
from that period.
Baker House is built in 1947,
and it's really the beginning.
We've talked about this before,
I think, of the
residential part of campus
growing on the west side of
Mass Ave. and then on down
the street, of course.
The other dorms are
built then.
The mid-century convocation is
1949, when Winston Churchill
comes to town and speaks.
And, again, sort of says MIT
has an obligation to think,
not just about the sciences and
technology it's creating,
but what are the social
implications of those
technologies.
And that's when--
the School of Humanities and
Social Sciences is founded,
essentially, right after
he says that in 1949.
And also at that mid-century
convocation is the
inauguration of James
Frank Killian--
James Killian, James
R. Killian,
forget his middle name--
as president.
He's the first alumni, alumnus,
to become president,
which is kind of interesting.
It took almost 100 years
for that to happen.
And he's as much of a kind of
executive manager, not a
career scientist, in the way
that his predecessor Karl
Compton was.
He really ran MIT during World
War II when Compton, as we
mentioned, was off around the
globe getting these weapons
into service.
So what is the end of this sort
of early Cold War period?
When does the world that this
film is describing really come
to a shocking end?
AUDIENCE: Sputnik.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
October 4, 1957 you
have Sputnik.
We read a piece about that.
And there is this just this
incredible sense of shock.
You can see from this video--
I actually don't remember what
the year on this was--
1956, so right before then.
And there's a sort of sense of
arrogant confidence that we're
doing everything right, and the
whole world follows us.
Couple people raised this in
the response papers, too.
And then Sputnik is launched.
And it's this incredible
shock to the American
system because suddenly--
it's somewhat similar
to the explosion
of the Soviet H-bomb.
Remember, we come
out of the war.
We have this world-changing
new weapon and
nobody else has it.
And then, not only the Soviets
get that one, but
they get the A-bomb.
They get the H-bomb, also,
in very short order.
And there's a lot happening in
the '50s, and there's a lot of
debate going on.
And people see space, somewhat
like computing, as sort of
like this exotic new field.
Nobody's quite sure what it's
good for, but it must be
important for the military
somehow.
And there's a lot of
debate about that.
Meanwhile, President Eisenhower
is this sort of
interesting, ironic figure in
that we have a military
general in the White House,
which doesn't happen that
often in American history.
And yet, at the same time,
he's a conservative
Republican.
He wants to keep government
small.
He wants to rein things in and
control military spending as
best he can.
He actually calls military
spending theft at one point.
But in a certain sense, he's
pushed by the forces of
history in ways that he's not
able to control and is,
actually, not very sensitive
to what Sputnik means.
And a lot of people aren't,
even as soon as
it first goes up.
And somebody mentioned
this about--
why wasn't the US first?
Well, partly the US wasn't first
because they didn't see
that being first was going
to be a priority.
And it wasn't, necessarily, an
objective comparison of US
technical competence versus
Soviet technical competence.
That's how most people in the
world, including in Congress
and the American public and
the media, read it, but it
wasn't necessarily that way.
Eisenhower was very concerned
about some of the legal
implications of--
if you send a satellite over
somebody's territory, is that
considered an invasion, or
is the space above your--
it had already been legally
established that air space is
like territory.
You can't go into it
without permission.
But that wasn't established
about orbital space.
And they were actually,
in some ways, happy.
One of the Assistant Secretaries
of Defense
immediately wrote, "The Russians
have, in fact, done
us a good turn in establishing
the concept of the freedom of
international space." And now
we can overfly them with
impunity because they've
done it to us.
And so, there was this
sort of question.
Eisenhower said, "Sputnik
does not rouse my
apprehension not one iota.
They've put one small
ball into the air."
Yet, the press assumed that this
meant Soviet superiority
in technology.
They sort of pushed
the panic button.
People in Congress, particularly
Lyndon Johnson,
took every opportunity
to rub it in.
Let me see if I have
the quote.
Because the US military said,
oh, that's not a big deal.
We have four projects that
are going to get that
going, at the time.
And Johnson said, in public, he
said, knowing that we have
better rockets on the drawing
boards is not very reassuring.
It's like being told that, I
suppose, our next model will
have tail fins and automatic
windshield wipers, which was
sort of the sarcastic comment
about what we're going to do.
What they hadn't really
recognized was that space was
this incredibly, symbolically,
potent thing and that people
responded to it way out of
proportion to what the direct
implications of it were.
If the US had decided that
being first in space was
important, they probably could
have rushed ahead and gone
first in space.
They didn't.
They had some bureaucratic
infighting.
They had the unfortunate failure
of another rocket
right after there.
And the world really changed,
in 1957, from a science and
technology point of view
in this country.
I teach a lot about
science policy.
And one of the things you learn
about science policy in
this country is that practically
every agency that
exists in the federal government
concerned with
science and technology arose in
response to a crisis of one
kind or another.
The most recent example is the
Department of Homeland
Security, which was created
after 9/11.
No matter what a good idea they
thought it might have
been or not been beforehand, it
was a response to crisis.
And after Sputnik, you had
several things which were
really quite important for MIT
and for the development of
technology.
One was reorganizing R&D in
the Defense Department to
avoid what they called
technological surprise.
And that involved creating a new
agency called the Advanced
Research Project Agency,
called ARPA, which
was founded in 1958.
Its first director was a
professor from MIT named Jack
Ruina, who's still around.
And I'll talk about that a
little bit in a minute.
Vastly increased accelerations
in R&D funding and also, of
course, the NACA, National
Advisory Committee for
Aeronautics became what?
NASA, National Air and Space
Administration in 1958.
Both those agencies were
founded in 1958.
And then there's also
the National Defense
Education Act in 1958.
This may sound like a long time
ago, but most, if not
many, of your professors--
if they're older, age 50--
were probably educated with
funds from that Act, including
President Susan Hockfield.
She came here-- in her inaugural
speech she said, I
was a post-Sputnik child.
I was educated and got into
science because there was a
huge push in scientific
education in the late '50s and
early '60s to get kids
into science.
And I was one of the
beneficiaries of that.
So we're very much living in
this kind of post-Sputnik
world in that way.
And I want to talk
then a little bit
about ARPA and DARPA.
Show you a couple more movies
that take this whole same
story, in a way, into
another realm.
People have heard of DARPA
before this, right?
Has anybody not heard
of DARPA?
So, obviously, it's most famous
because the internet
started as the ARPANET and was
created in very much this
period, slightly after, but
only in the early '60s.
And one of the things
about computing--
one of things that's special
about DARPA was that it's not
the Office of Naval Research
or the Air Force Office of
Scientific Research or the
Army Research Lab.
ARPA reports directly to the
Secretary of Defense, so it's
outside of all of these
inter-service rivalries.
And it doesn't own-- in fact,
it tends to stay away from
things like big ships and big
airplanes, much like the OSRD
did, and focus on these
technologies that are so far
out and wacky that nobody
really knows what
they're good for.
At the time, space
was one of them.
In fact, ARPA was responsible
for space until--
it was only a few months
NASA was created--
and then they had space
taken away from them.
And computing was another one.
That everybody had the sense it
was good for something but
nobody really knew what.
And so let me show you a
coupleof images, couple of
other neat little films about
what some of the ARPA
computing work did.
So that's another kind of late
'50s version of this whole
idea of machine control, which
is Air Force still and not
ARPA funded.
But then you get into the
ARPA-funded stuff.
So this is sort of the
next logical step in
a lot of this work.
And Ivan Sutherland is someone
who's, remarkably, still alive
today, too.
Not that he's remarkably
still alive,but.
He went from here out to the
University of Utah where he
founded the computer graphics
program there.
And practically every
fundamental concept in
computer graphics came out of
either his work or his lab.
And then his students went on
to found Silicon Graphics,
Adobe, many of the other
really critical--
a lot of them worked for
Industrial Light and Magic,
the George Lucas company and
sort of migrated west,
continuing into Hollywood.
Pixar, that was the other one
I was trying to think of.
And that, again, comes
from this.
We didn't watch that part of the
film on SAGE, but they had
these light pens in SAGE, too,
as the beginning of this sort
of graphical user interface.
And then the last one I want
to show you about has to do
with time-sharing.
So Corbato is still around.
I saw him last week,
and he still
teaches in computer science.
And they came up with this
time-sharing system where--
I mean, how many of you use
a console window ever
on your Mac or PC?
So, basically, that's the idea
behind time-sharing.
That you have a computer there,
before a graphical
interface, that you could type
commands and programs to, and
it would respond to
you immediately.
Before that, you had only batch
processing, where you'd
put your punch cards in at
night, and you go home and
come back the next morning, and
there would be the thing.
And they're again, following
this thread.
There was this idea that you
could be so much more creative
with a computer if you could sit
there and hack away at it,
and it would respond to
you in real time.
And that's really where
time-sharing comes from.
That led to a thing called
Project MAC in the 1960s,
which was a DARPA funded--
it was the predecessor to the
Laboratory for Computer
Science, which is now CSAIL.
And Project MAC was run by Bob
Fano, who I mentioned before.
And had all these different
kinds of creative computing
things inside it, including a
lot of Minsky's work in AI,
although they split out and
formed a separate AI lab.
Then they came together
with CSAIL.
And all these sort of
time-sharing experiments, the
origins of a lot of the
late-night hacker culture from
MIT, come from people working
late at night
on Project MAC projects.
A lot of the early computer
games, Spacewar and whatnot,
were developed in
that context.
And even a lot of the early
later stuff for PCs, like
spreadsheets, sort
of came out of a
Project MAC sort of setting.
And then I also mentioned, of
course, the internet, or the
early ARPANET, one of
the first nodes on
the ARPANET was MIT.
A lot of the first routers were
built by a company called
Bolt, Beranek, and Newman, which
still exists here, sort
of down the street.
So there's this sort of
continuous thread that's then
updated through all these
different crises and periods
and whatnot.
And through the '60s, that's
sort of how this very, very
heavily military still, but sort
of different agencies and
different contexts bears
on the campus.
I think you're right on.
I mean, I think the atomic bomb
had a lot to do with--
it's hard for us to imagine,
but before
World War II, two things.
First of all, science was
mostly the realm of
pointy-headed professors and
was very interesting and
philosophically important but
didn't always feel like it had
a big impact on daily life and
certainly not on public
policy, per se.
Again, the US government was
hardly involved in the
scientific world.
Maybe in the world of
agriculture it seemed to have
a big impact.
Most of industry didn't
have a lot of science
associated with it.
And it really took the atomic
bomb, not just for technology,
but also for science itself,
the idea that it--
like something that presidents
should care about.
I mean, even--
you look at the scientific
revolution and the Copernican
view of the universe--
doesn't affect the
way I govern my
kingdom an awful lot.
And secondly, same thing with
technology, where the idea
today that whoever has the best
technology wins the war
was just not an accepted idea.
And there was no real evidence
for it up until that point.
Maybe a little bit here in the
Naval arms race around the
turn of the 19th century, the
turn of the 20th century.
But today, almost everyone who
is a leader in the military is
trained in engineering in one
way or another, not everybody
but a very large
amount of them.
That was not true, even at the
beginning of World War II.
Military science was
this other thing.
There was this whole sort of
tradition about fighting wars.
There still is, still
very prominent.
And it took World War
II to really bring
those two ideas together.
And even then it was still a
little bit under question
because it was really about who
had the most planes and
the most tanks, not always the
best tanks and the best guns.
Then, to some degree, you can
say that Bush sort of served
as the president's science
adviser during the
Second World War.
But, again, most of the
decisions to be made were
either grand political decisions
for the president as
far as how to be allied with
the Soviet Union and how to
work with the British.
And at the same time,
military decisions--
where do we invade?
At what time do we do it?
And there's technologies that
bear on that, but they're not
things that rise to the
presidential level.
It's really during the Cold
War that you see the
prevalence of atomic
weapons and ICBMs.
Again, ICBMs don't really come
out until the late '50s.
It's all through the Cold War
you're living with bombers and
nuclear bombs that are as big
as this room that you need a
huge bomber to deliver.
That's why something
like SAGE came out.
It's only around the late '50s
you get this sense of mutual
assured destruction, where we've
got all these missiles
ready to go, and they've
got all these
missiles ready to go.
That's the world that
dominated the
next 30 years or so.
And that's where arms control,
different technical issues,
become merged with politics
in a way.
And the presidential
science adviser--
it varies from administration
to administration--
but it's never been as prominent
a position as it was
when Killian and Wiesner
were in that job.
Nixon actually outright
abolished it in the '70s,
didn't want it all.
Anybody know why that's
a troubled position?
So it's sort of science policy
talk more than an MIT talk,
but it's relevant.
There's an inherent
contradiction in being the
president's science advisor.
AUDIENCE: It's not pure
science [? anymore ?]
PROFESSOR: That's true.
There's a lot of people
who do that.
So, first of all, are you
representing to the president
the conclusions of the
scientific community, or are
you representing the president's
opinion and his
policy goals to the scientific
community?
Right?
And those things can easily
be 180 degrees at odds.
In fact, the story was-- this
was all kind of leaked in the
newspaper--
that George W. Bush
asked Chuck Vest
to be science adviser.
And Vest said no because he
felt he would be forced to
take positions on things like
climate change that he didn't
think were going to be
acceptable to him.
So, if you look at what the
Secretary of Defense does, or
even the head of NASA, their job
is to take the president's
policies and implement them
through the agency.
And any time a big decision
comes up you'll always see
them on TV saying, well,
that's for the
president to decide.
Robert Gates doesn't decide
whether we're in
Afghanistan or not.
That's the president's
job to decide that.
Well, what happens when--
in the defense world, at least
there's an understanding that
decisions on defense
are sort of partly
political and whatnot.
In the science world that's
not so clear.
And there's any number of cases
where the president's
policy preferences are at odds
with what the science says,
and that was very clear in the
previous administration.
But I'm sure that John Holdren,
who is now the
president's science adviser,
who is a much more powerful
guy and better-respected science
adviser and scientist
than the previous guy was,
gets pulled in a lot of
competing directions
all the time.
So it's a very difficult
job and not
everyone succeeds at that.
I thought it was interesting
that, even in the little,
short film clip I showed you
about the APT programming
language, the guy on the board
said, well, now there's a new
kind of person in here who is
the kind of machine-oriented
programmer.
And he's going to take these
requirements and--
let me give you a little
background on David Noble,
which is actually interesting.
He was a professor here in the
kind of early to mid-1980s and
was in STS and did a lot of
collaboration with the
engineering departments.
And he wrote this book that was
extremely critical of both
the Air Force and MIT's role
in numerically-controlled
machine tools.
And he was turned down for
tenure a couple years later,
and ended up suing MIT.
He said because he was a
Marxist, and they turned him
down for tenure because
he was a Marxist.
MIT's response was, you didn't
get denied tenure because
you're a Marxist.
You got denied tenure because
you're a jerk.
And that's actually legal.
It's not legal to deny
tenure to someone
because of their politics.
It is legal to deny tenure to
them because of their personal
style of interaction.
I don't know many of
the stories there.
And I actually only have
met the guy once.
He died about three months ago
at a fairly young age.
And he's a well-respected
historian.
And he's always raised these
sort of questions about these
kinds of arrangements.
And it's very worth reading it
because of the questions it
raises, although I do think he
misses a couple of things--
kind of like what you said.
In his world-- and I don't
remember if this comes through
in that essay or if it's
in the larger book--
people who operate computers are
managers, and people who
operate machines are workers.
And anything like
numerically-controlled machine
tools has that worker--
white-collar managers oppressing
the workers.
I mean, first of all today,
almost everybody sits in front
of a computer.
Many, many jobs-- some of them
are high-level executives and
some of them are blue-collar
operatives--
but the fact that you're using
a computer has almost nothing
to say about what level
job you're in.
And in the world that he came
out of, he only had this
association of white-collar
managers.
So anytime anything became
computerized, it also became
white collarized for him.
Where, actually, we actually
know today that the opposite
is often the case.
That when something becomes
computerized, the skill level
of the people who operate the
computer is lower than the
skill level of the people who
did it before it was operated.
And it's funny because he
actually wrote an essay, after
he wrote the book, about a
study of machine tools in
Sweden, where he was like, oh
look, they did it this way.
It's much more democratic and
open, the way they use
numerically-controlled
machine tools.
And there's an implication
in his work that a given
technology has a given social
organization that comes along
with it because of what's
inherent in the technology.
That's basically what he
says in that "Command
Performance" piece.
And the jargon in the field is
called, it's deterministic.
A certain technology dictates
a certain set of social
conditions.
But actually, if there's one
thing we know from research in
the field is that you can have
lots of different social
organizations around any
particular technology.
You can use the internet as
a tool of authoritarian
repression, or you can use the
internet as a tool of people's
liberation.
Depends how you use it, but the
tool itself can be used in
different ways.
I don't think that Noble would
have seen himself, at the
time, as a technological
determinist, although, to some
degree, all Marxists are
technological determinists
because Marx was a technological
determinist.
He said--
I'm not going to get the quote
exactly right, but
it's sort of like--
the spinning wheel gives
you feudal society.
Industrial production gives
you capitalist society.
And he, more or less,
put it that way.
And we actually know that's just
empirically incorrect.
What Noble did say that I think
is really valuable to
keep in mind that underlies a
lot of the stuff that we saw
in the video is that--
what are the implications of all
of this military funding
going to support university
research and engineering
research and scientific
research?
And I've tried to show the
connections between where the
money comes from and what the
ideas are that got created.
And I think one of the most
legitimate criticisms of it is
that military systems end up
focusing almost exclusively on
performance.
And that's kind of the title
of his piece, "Command
Performance." That everyone
was always pushing toward
thinner wings and more precise
tools and, obviously, faster
airplanes, bigger bombs,
heavier rockets.
You don't care about costs.
You don't, necessarily, care as
much about schedule, other
things which are sort of related
like maintainability,
sustainability.
Lots of other ways to think
about how a system performs
besides simply performance.
You know, an interesting example
of that was the-- has
anybody ever heard of the SST?
What was the SST?
AUDIENCE: Boeing's supersonic
transport [INAUDIBLE].
Newer version of the Concorde.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So Boeing was trying to make,
in the '60s, a supersonic
transport--it was actually a
competitor to the Concorde--
that would be Mach 3.
And it was a big American
project.
And the idea was, gee, the
Wright brothers were going at
20 miles an hour, and we went
200 miles an hour in 1940.
And we're doing 500 miles
an hour with jet
aircraft in the '60s.
Clearly, the whole world is
going to go supersonic.
And if you focus only on
performance, as the military
does, and sure enough,
military systems go
supersonic.
And that's the faster, the
better, generally.
Also just straight
economics of--
I just read this
the other day.
The Concorde took as much fuel
to put 100 people across the
Atlantic as a 747
takes to put 400
people across the Atlantic.
So, just run the numbers
on that.
AUDIENCE: Also, there
was the huge noise
problem with the Concorde.
PROFESSOR: Noise problems.
AUDIENCE: Anyone who lived
anywhere near the place where
it lands with the rumbling.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So actually it's a very
interesting moment because, in
the civilian world, the
cancellation of the SST and a
lot of other things that
happened in 1970 are all about
this sort of, like,
you know what?
Performance isn't the
be all and end all.
There are other things that
matter with our systems like,
especially, cost because
that's a
straight economic one.
But also environmental impact in
a bunch of different ways,
whether it's noise
or emissions.
Reliability is a big one that
often ends up being cost.
And the reason I'm bringing this
up, partly, is it gets us
to a little bit later part of
MIT's life in the 1980s.
What's happening in the 1980s?
Maybe this is the Sputnik
moment of the 1980s.
Actually, it's not as
much of a moment.
What causes the US
a big crisis of
confidence in the 1980s?
AUDIENCE: There was
a fuel crisis.
PROFESSOR: OK, the fuel crisis
precipitates it for sure.
That's in the '70s
really, 1973.
What's the big issue
in the '80s?
AUDIENCE: Iran-Contra.
Iran-Contra, or is that
the late 70's?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
political more.
That's '80s.
But it's the Japanese
car companies
start eating our lunch.
And we have the greatest car
industry in the world--
General Motors and Henry Ford,
and we invented it all.
And suddenly, Toyota and Honda,
which were making
motorcycles, start coming in.
And not only are they doing well
economically, but their
cars are better.
They get better mileage.
They're much higher quality.
And the American car companies
just will not listen
or learn from it.
And then people say,
very much like with
Sputnik, what do you mean?
We're the most technologically
advanced nation in the world
with the biggest economy.
How is it that these car
companies from this little
island that we defeated in World
War II are now doing so
much better than us?
And it led to this thing
called the crisis of
competitiveness.
You may hear that phrase
sometimes.
It was a big issue
in the '80s.
And one of the things people
said was, gee, are we not
spending enough on R&D?
Now we're spending tons and tons
on R&D, but it's all in
the military realm or so heavily
in the military realm.
And the military is focusing
on performance--
very, very high-speed computers,
very, very advanced
materials for this, that,
and the other thing.
And none of that technology is
getting out of the lab into
the field as much.
MIT does a big study in--
I want to say it comes
out in about 1988--
called Made in America.
And it's edited by Richard
Lester, who is now the head of
nuclear engineering, Michael
Dertouzos, who is the Director
of the Computer Science
Laboratory, a few others,
Lester Thurow, who is the Noble
Prize winner, Dean of
the Sloan School.
And Made in America
sort of says--
how do we get the same level
of achievement in the
manufacturing industry in this
country that we've got in the
military industry?
And there's a whole series of
concrete steps that they
suggest to do that.
One of them is creating a dual
master's program, which is
still here, called--
it was called Leaders for
Manufacturing, where you get a
master's at Sloan and a master's
in engineering.
They changed the name, and I
think it's Leaders for Global
Systems or something now.
So the competitiveness crisis
very much came up as, like,
this military focuses too
much on performance,
too much only on--
if you look in AeroAstro, it's
all about supersonic, or
dynamics, and not enough about
more efficient engines or
cleaner engines.
And there really was a
kind of shift after
the '80s toward that.
Interestingly enough, another
flip side of that, which a lot
of people don't realize--
because someone mentioned it
in one of your response
papers that--
well, you know, it looks like
when I'm in my double E
classes, I end up learning a lot
about consumer technology.
And I'm building mobile
technology and
mobile this and that.
And where does all that
stuff come from?
Where do we end up developing
advanced, small RF and
microwave integrated circuits?
I can tell you that stuff wasn't
originally developed
for the cell phone industry.
That was all military
communications stuff.
And Qualcomm and a lot of those
other big companies
really developed a lot
of those techniques
early in that world.
Then, there is a general
consensus, probably somewhere
in the '90s, the sophistication
of computation
and information technology in
the commercial world exceeded
that of what happens in
the military world.
Now I go to meetings and half
the problem is, how does the
Navy and the Air Force take
advantage of all the amazing
stuff that's coming out instead
of having obsolete
electronics and all
those things.
But that was somewhere
in there.
What's their concern?
Well, actually it was something
that was raised by
Norbert Wiener, late in his
career in the early '60s, that
all of this automatic technology
was going to put
all the workers out of work.
And I think the Air Force
was then concerned--
gee, is there going to be a
workers' revolt, and we're
going to be facing a communist
revolution sort of thing?
So when people talked about
social implications of
automation, they talked about
technological unemployment,
essentially.
Some of which did come to pass,
and there's certainly
fields today.
I think, today, it gets more
called outsourcing than it
does called replacing workers,
but it has the same effect on
unemployment in this country.
And it is interesting,
especially at a place like
Boeing, where all the engineers
at Boeing are
basically workers.
They're unionized.
And Boeing, these days, makes
big decisions based on their
relationships with their unions,
both machinists and
the engineers.
And so, again, the clean
distinction between factory
workers as blue collar and
white-collar engineers--
engineers in many places are
more and more like blue-collar
workers in a lot of ways, partly
because of CAD and
computer-aided design.
How many people in here have
ever designed a circuit,
actually designed a new circuit
that no one's built?
I mean, I can open up my CAD
software, and I get a library
of all these demo circuits,
and I can sort of copy and
this sort of thing.
And there's certainly changes
that have come into what
engineering practice means in
a lot of different fields
because of computer-aided design
in different ways.
Which, arguably, maybe makes it
easier to outsource jobs in
ways than it was before.
Running a university has become
a 24-hour job in a way
that maybe it wasn't always
before, partly for reasons
that all jobs have become
so 24-hours.
And it's just a very
big complex place,
and it's harder for--
it's hard to picture an
MIT president taking a
simultaneous job in
the government.
I don't remember what Killian
did, if he stepped down when
he took that job, or if he did
them both at the same time and
for how long.
And yet, at the same time,
the presidents do--
like, Chuck Vest chaired one of
the big review committees
on the space station, and it's
called the Vest Report.
And it was kind of a midway
design review in the early
'90s, and the cultural authority
of being the MIT
president, I think, had
a lot of impact there.
And he sat on the President's
Council on Competitiveness.
And I don't know what Susan
Hockfield's official titles
are that way.
But she does--
when Obama rolled out a big
energy initiative two or three
years ago that was part of his
administration's science
policy, she was standing
right there next
to him on the stage.
So she's very involved with
presidential science
advice in that way.
And I think it's also true that
different presidents just
emphasize different
parts of the role.
There is a sense--
and Chuck Vest was extremely
enthusiastic about this--
where, from this earlier history
of a lot of these
things you've read about by now,
there is a sense that the
president of MIT is not just
in Washington speaking for
MIT, but is speaking for the
research enterprise in general
and research universities
in general.
And that the kind of privilege
of the bully pulpit that you
get from being the president of
MIT is not used to go down
to Washington to just scoop up
more money for Cambridge.
Clearly, we've seen
that happen quite
a lot in the history.
But also to go down and speak
for research overall and why
it's important to maintain
that in the economy.
And when Vest became president,
which I think was
'91, was really right after the
fall of the Berlin Wall.
And there was this thing people
kept talking about
called the peace dividend.
And there was the sense that
all of that DOD funding--
and some of it really
did-- was about to
fall off the cliff.
And people were really
questioning, why are we
spending money on universities
at all.
When Newt Gingrich was Speaker
of the House, he basically
wanted to end it altogether, and
Vest, and a lot of related
similar people, really spoke
out against that.
By the way, that's about
to happen again.
And I do think you'll see Susan
Hockfield in Washington
speaking on that behalf.
Anybody see her?
She was on Charlie Rose a couple
of months ago with the
President of Harvard talking
about almost
exactly that topic.
So I think there's a lot
of behind the scenes
work that goes on.
It's not necessarily secret or
hidden, but it doesn't have a
big public role.
And at the same time-- you know,
MIT has an office in
Washington.
And the guy who runs it is a
very experienced guy, and they
are registered lobbyists.
And they're extremely effective
at taking MIT
professors and showing them
around Washington.
And I know this because about
2 and 1/2 years ago, I was
part of a group that wrote
a report on space policy.
And we called these guys
up-- we developed it in
parallel with them.
And within a few weeks, we were
sitting in the room with
the transition team for Obama,
who was working on NASA, and
the people in the White House
who work on space policy.
And that's what lobbyists do.
They open the door, and
they get you in there.
Now they're not lobbyists in the
sense of they go down and
say, give us more money, but
they have to be registered
because they are performing
that function.
Now, MIT hasn't always had that
office in Washington, and
may not always have that office
in Washington, but
there's a lot of that sort
of stuff that goes on.
So, it is harder to picture--
again, I think it has much to
do with just the demands on
one's time than happened
before.
Fundraising--
most of what the president does
these days is fundraising
as far as out on the road,
getting the alumni excited
about what's going on here.
And that's a pretty
time-consuming job.
Any other comments about that?
It's not an exaggeration to
say the field of computer
science was created by DARPA
over about 25-year period from
1960 to 1985 or so.
And then from Star Wars, which
is a separate agency but
similar kind of thing.
Just wouldn't exist without
that kind of money.
Still today, a lot of the CSAIL
funds are from DARPA, in
a lot of different ways, or
other parts of the military.
How many people here
have worked on an
industrially-funded project?
Nobody?
How many people here know where
the funding comes from
for the projects you work on?
Only a few.
OK, interesting.
So you know, again, the military
funding is not
as big as it was.
I think it's very clear to say
the mindset of that kind of
work does not dominate the way
that it did during the period
when we were watching those.
But there's still a lot of it,
and the industrial funding has
its own set issues, too.
And then there's always new
forms of this kind of thing.
What's down the street there--
down the street, it's right
over there-- is the Koch
Institute that opened up just,
what, a month ago.
And that would seem to
be, oh, how perfect.
It's endowed by a private
individual.
Doesn't have any of the strings
that government or
industrial funding comes with
or any of the sort of
implications, but what were the
issues there that came up?
Anybody read about it when the
Koch Institute was opened?
Well, that man, David Koch, he
has a lot of funding for other
kinds of political--
well, not other kinds--
but political.
He funds a lot of Tea Party,
right-wing conservative stuff
in the country.
I mean, MIT is very clear about
what the boundaries are
for what's acceptable when
money is accepted.
I mean, there's any
number times.
It's happened to me.
I had, essentially, a contract
with an oil company that
wanted to fund some of the work
I did C, but they had a
restriction in what the contract
was supposed to say
about intellectual property.
That's actually the place
it most comes up.
That was just totally
unacceptable, both to me and
to the lawyers at MIT, who
looked at it, and we ended up
not taking the money because you
couldn't work under those
conditions.
And those things get massaged
in a lot of different ways,
but people have a pretty clear
sense of their intellectual
freedom and aren't always
willing to sell
that off in that way.
So, there's all sorts
of things.
Another one that comes up
a lot now is foreign
governments.
And we have a lot of potential
arrangements with foreign
governments that raise
interesting questions.
Like, say the government of
India were to come to MIT and
say, we'd like to give you $50
million to help study poverty.
Well, a lot of professors on
campus would say, I don't feel
comfortable taking research
money from a country that has
x numbers of hundreds of
millions of poor people in
their country and shouldn't be
MIT's role in the world to
take money from governments that
have very, very serious
pressing things.
Or Saudi Arabia, where they
don't allow women students or
women professors or Jewish
students or Jewish professors
on their campuses.
Should we go into collaborations
with them?
So it's actually pretty hard
to think about a source of
funding that comes to the
Institute that doesn't have
some kind of complicated set
of circumstances around it.
And that's one of the
interesting things in your own
work but also, as a historian,
to look at this about how
those things get negotiated
in any given era.
There's certainly, clearly,
things that are just off
limits that won't be done.
There are other things that
are pretty easy, like the
National Science Foundation,
where they come and they give
you money and your only job in
response is to write a paper.
And there's a lot of
things that are
kind of in the middle.
I actually happen to think
that some of the military
funding, particularly the DARPA
funding, is actually a
lot freer and has fewer strings
attached than the NSF
funding because the NSF is
always peer reviewed.
And you're always being pulled
by other people in your field
who want you to do
what they do.
Whereas with, sometimes, with
what-- it's a little bit less
true now than it used to be--
with DARPA funding, they can
really just give you the money
and let you do want you want to
do because they're a little
bit protected politically
because
they're within the DOD.